we have hardware on the set everybody we
have hardware on the set and it is in
the lap of the champ who is here he is
the UFC middleweight champion was taken
over UFC certainly in his weight class
since joining it less than two years ago
he is Israel Otto Sonya good to see you
sir
thanks for being here not things I
haven't you got it that is a pretty
that's a beautiful belt you got there in
your lap that's work that is yeah what
does that mean to you sit there in your
lap but it looks good on you matches
everything else I see this is a really
like this is this is like the goal for
most people but for me it's just like I
say another hardware but beating all the
baddest dudes in Mike my error in my
weight class and out of my weight class
that's the real challenge and that's the
real gold to me well I mean has this
been what you envision 100% I'm about
maybe 10 months ahead of schedule but
you know I work well I work fast why'd
you do this what you gonna do this I
didn't want to when I first started
watching The Ultimate Fighter in 2005
the first season I mean you couldn't pay
me to get into the cage with another
crazy crazy dude and beat him up or get
beat up I wanted Dana White's job
actually so I can get to pick who gets
the fight and then you told Dana that
that did and now I don't want his job I
see how you know not straight up he he
works hard and he's a stressful dude I
can understand cuz yeah having a company
like this on your back having to do what
he does right no thanks but so walk me
through you were in New Zealand when you
saw this for the first time right how
old were you I was about maybe 2005
maybe 16 so you're 16 years old sitting
in New Zealand you saw this and it
caught your eye though I mean what yeah
I started watching that beforehand maybe
around 14 through DVDs okay but then
when I first I watch it alls gonna
fighter I felt I was already like into
fighting but I was never exactly the
toughest guy in the room and I picked
this up just to learn how to defend
myself because I still get picked on a
lot so over time I'm like you know I'm
big and black I don't play basketball or
from Nigeria I don't play soccer mmm New
Zealand I won't play rugby I just
somehow learn I'm pretty good at this
I'm pretty pretty good at kicking ass
and yeah Here I am
well it's interesting that you just said
what you just said I want to pick up on
something you
picked on your Boyd 1% I was it see I
had the same size head but a skinny
buddy so I look like a lollipop so I see
get messed with a lot really easily and
I just had to learn how to defend myself
so I wasn't gonna turn my back on people
I was good at running very fast at some
points but you know turn around and
fight at some point cuz you know III
know you're having a little bit of fun
with it but it is as you know as I'm
sure it's a serious subject you
understand and the fact that you are
you've got that belt there right in
front of you and you're I see to use
your phrase right now I am always I say
it's do you feel like you're
inspirational to kid I know it's tough
to say that but I mean do people take
inspiration from my journey you know
kudos to them and I told some kids when
I spoke to the mess cause I look cuz you
know especially in New Zealand the
suicide rates for the youth is the
highest I think in the world pound for
pound and I told those kids like just if
I could go back to my younger self
I'd just say keep going this isn't
forever because a lot of kids think
that's this is it for everything right
ticked on the can sort of the
perspective of the miles ahead one can
make yourself so I say hey don't peak in
high school cuz trust me you can peak
later on and I'm not even in my peak my
peak yet I'm still working it's just a
new chapter so I tell them don't peak in
high school Israel out of Sanya here on
the Rich Eisen show so then let's get
into your your last fight against Robert
Whittaker a right front of by the way
the largest audience largest attendance
for live UFC fight ever 57,000 and
change in Marvel Stadium in Australia
what did that mean for you to you mmm
that was it didn't really feel like that
until after the fight for me I never
really suck all that until I get the job
done then I soaked all that in
especially doing it in his home country
in his you know in his backyard yes I
took him out so afterwards yeah I bask
in the ambience and yeah it was pretty
nice nice wave to ride
well I knew also we just showed him a
television audience let's bring it to
the radio audience to the way you came
out of the tunnel hmm apparently your
dance that you did the you everybody now
wants to do something like that yeah see
are you aware that you've started
something I don't think everyone can do
something like that
cojones I know the cojones to be able to
come out you know with a walkout like
that and then go to a knock out like
that so yeah for me it's you know I
showed you where my where my mind was
that a guy like a robber was probably
stewing over the fight the whole time
you know for weeks I had days ahead just
going and it's called paralysis over
analysis so for me all I was worried
about was man I'm gonna look clean I'm
gonna look cool as hell you know and I'm
doing this and then when I pull this off
I'm gonna be the man so that was where
my mind was that Naz relax you can see
it when were in the cage he was pacing
back and forth like a caged animal and
it's so dangerous even a cat he's a
corner a cat the mess you up
but I was the hunter he was the prey and
I was looking at him exactly that way
and then you went into the cage and you
took care of business you sure had a
businessman so what's next what's next I
have options I like that I like having
options let's go through them what are
your office like my buffet you know I
have a few guys on the list my man right
there Tim Simpson with paradigm they've
been working behind the scenes at the
UFC and we got some options in I having
a guy who's on a losing streak right now
I he's the guy that that's the boogeyman
no one calls him out of the division and
I kept I said let's go I don't care if
he's lost his last three you know three
out of four fights I just said if you
guys think he can beat me let's get it
but the UFC they say it's hard to sell
that they say he needs a win at least
before it comes take a shot at champ
okay so who do you wanna face I wanted
to face him but right now we're working
on some things so I can't really oh come
on
I can't you're dressed up you dressed up
you got your I see you got the belt
right here yeah why they say I want who
the best man is I want who the best man
is and I've said I called that guy out
and even them it's his name Darren's
Hill as well just had a good wind but
mmm it was I split decision went over my
last opponent on my previous previous
opponent right I think me and him
eventually in future we'll have a good
throwdown
what do you think of till saying that
before he walked out he considered
faking an injury to avoid fighting what
do you think of that I think that's very
honest of him and I can't say I relate
you know I understand the nerves that
you get before fighting we all still
have them right what's about how you
channel that are you gonna let that burn
your house
you're gonna use that to to smoke a dude
so I know how to breathe I know how to
focus and use that and chant on it like
a Hadouken at the right time huh so
you've never thought I'm a fake an
injury
oh no no or just that I don't I don't
know if I'm up maybe when I was younger
like when I made my second fight one of
my first fight actually my first ever
fight when I was in when I was in the
ring with the guy he looked like a yeah
he looked like a killer and I was
thinking in my head like you know fight
you're about to get knocked out and I
was thinking oh yeah just I've seen guys
do it as well when they get kicked in
the leg they just falling gonna get back
up and I'm like yeah you took a dive why
did you mention John Jones's name John
he mentioned my name first okay so your
name was in his mouth before before
anything else for yeah you got to keep
on your mother's mouth why okay why do
you think your name was in his mouth cuz
I'm the freshman you know I'm the guy
that he wishes he was I'm the guy that's
doing all these things that he he did
but then he messed it up by doing what
he did you know all I'm saying is you
know I keep my nose clean keep my my
head to the ground and I stay working
and he yeah he's kind of tarnished his
legacy in a lot of ways so would you if
the weight classes were repressing an
issue you know he says he's gonna go to
heavy weight trust me I have a plan
before I go into the UFC I hit Dana off
in 2015 and I took my time to get to the
UFC we had a whole schedule and my man
will not let me deviate from my schedule
so I said wait till I defend my bill a
lot of people just win the bill and they
want to have a super fight straight away
jump up weight class I'm like no I
respect the game do what got you to the
dance and respect the game of the game
will humble you so I'm gonna respect the
game a defendant my belt once I guess
rubber Whitaker I'm gonna defend a few
more times just four more times next
year I want to defend it and the rate
they're smart they see the rate I'm
evolving if you want to beat me you
gotta beat me yesterday all day before
yesterday cuz every fight I'm getting
better and better and better so give me
some time let me work and I said radar
stadium 2020 2021 sorry in Las Vegas
that's where he's gonna get this work
okay no you just said a lot let me take
this alright
breathe breathe it's real lot of Sonia
here on the rich artichoke here huh you
said breathe whose son what is he what
do you say okay so
woosah I said I thought I did that right
yeah um so you came up with a plan in
2015 you wrote it did you write it down
I slid into dating-wise dm's and I said
this is a slam at the end no I know
that's so so you did you did that yeah
you know who you were at this point you
didn't see it till like last year and
when I actually pointed it out to him no
kidding yeah so I just said to him was
get me one chance just get me today off
the gun and I'll take care of the rest
because I knew once they had a taste you
know like a bad habit they gonna keep
coming back for more so your plan was
what walk me through it your plan was
your schedule so I know we're now in
November of 2019 so you wanted to come
in dominate win this bill at this weight
class is that the okay episode and then
and then defend it dominate it and then
move up and wait because every champion
I've done it in kickboxing I've done in
boxing I move up and waiting for some
world champions and you know I can't say
that for everyone else but when you
clean out your division when you clean
out all the killers in your division you
got to move up and wait and like I said
my man you know homeboy him you know he
keeps fighting middleweights
you know like reject middleweights name
uh I want to give him a little shine
it's my time okay okay you do have
wonderful pieces of jewelry I Sur you
know this one is that belt that's right
there say no gucci belt free blood but
jones you think is mentioning you
because he's let's just state it Claire
TMZ was the first one TMZ shots at them
they're the pot stairs as well yeah they
they hit a blood they said who do you
want to fight and he kind of dropped my
name is mouth and then eventually they
asked me and I said I already killed one
goat I got a hunt the next and that's
where it all started
yeah but like I said I'm on schedule
right now ten months ahead but I feel
like you know everything is happening
the way it's supposed to happen
mm-hmm and then you'll eventually set
the stage for something
big yes hairless Stadium get lucky if he
goes to heavy weight like I said weight
isn't an issue out for a heavyweight I
for that my heavyweight cruiserweight in
boxing yeah anyone can get these hands
and feet why Raiders stadium I was in
the palms in July and then I was in my
hotel room and I was looking across and
seen it being built and yeah I just had
an epiphany I decided you know what
that's where that spectacular fight is
gonna happen just because you're sitting
in that hotel
I'd do what I do you look out the window
mm-hmm well I guess you could have
looked you could have seen all different
types of sites in Las Vegas Vegas
allegedly so then you see the stadium
you're like I want to have my big fight
in there and it seems like everything
you put your mind to it's actually
happen we're in the matrix I said man
I'm player 1 all these boys are just
loading man I'm player one I started the
game at level two okay I think I
understood what you deserve I'm a
50-year old man and I mean when we come
down to that and so the last style
bender that's based on on what it's
based off a TV show I watched the avatar
it's a Nickelodeon show okay and Aang
the main character he had to realize his
destiny as the avatar by mastering all
the four elements which is water earth
fire and air mm-hmm to realize his
destiny and for me and this in this
realm I have to realize my destiny as
the avatar by mastering all the elements
of the avatar of martial arts so a lot
of stuff in that show was what kind of
correlates with my life with different
characters so I got tough right here you
know I ain't too rough on my skin
because and I have a lot of other
tattoos that relate to that show okay
and even this one Naruto is another
anime i watch that really inspired me so
yeah you wearing that shirt yeah I just
picked it up this morning person you
know I dressed up nice look man again I
just you're so I see I couldn't really
tell everything scales if you want to
just die don't do it you slip and fall
huh I don't want you know I'm not gonna
break my hip you know I'm a shape I see
you
fifty-year-old I mean I'm not gonna get
in the cake I could not I don't know if
I could do that dance that you did I'll
show you a little two-step real quick so
you need is that it yeah okay yeah well
here's what we're gonna do you know
we're gonna keep you for a television
only segment and then you'll try and
teach you a little two-step yes I'd like
to do that I did I think you know I
limbered up I did a workout yesterday
fasciitis in my left foot you know but
you know that's just neither here nor
sounds fancy um no or load management I
should say I've got load management
going on but that would mean that I'm
not gonna do it
what do you do when you're not fighting
or preparing to fight what do you do I
like to chew I hang out my friends I
pretty much see this when the cameras
are on that can be extroverted look at
me when I'm in my house and my nest I'm
very interested yeah that's why I call
that my nest I said is if my favorite
spot in the world is this corner of my
couch with my blanket and I just showed
there and I like it yeah did you blank
it up and it was it or no it's just
fluffy okay just fluffy yeah okay do you
have a pet hey I got two dogs and a cat
and she's fluffy too oh okay yeah and
what are you are you watching anything
other than anime or what it flicks you
know right I finished money heist what
else am I on right now big mouth I was
in three I'm looking for three days Rick
and Morty what a little bit dub dub it's
coming through okay can't wait and now
the Rich Eisen genre yeah exactly
we're now like because this to me is
forever right now should Israel I feel
like boom I almost threw out my head no
in all honesty though I mean I feel like
we've we've connected in a way here at
this and then and then when you go on
and you envision your success ability
thanks to Rich Eisen I really appreciate
this correct just give me that shoutout
and then we'll be there in a trader
Stadium mm-hmm well if this happens it
will happen with me when it happens when
and when it happens we'll do it Congrats
on everything going so much it's been a
blast to meet you have fun
it has been fun I should be a studio
audience
come to the Superbowl come to the
Superbowl we have a studio on it so
simple all right
if you from around if I'm around I'll
have my people call your people well
yeah I mean it's in Miami it's in Miami
and Miami 305 come on by
alright at style bender on Twitter and
Instagram you've got 1.6 million
followers on instant 7 I'm sorry
according to Tim oh my gosh
that's called the Rich Eisen show bump
and that's what that's called my man at
style bender on Twitter Instagram Israel
Auto Sonia a lot of fun cool to see it
right here on the horizon show still to
come Devin Bush of the Pittsburgh
Steelers when we come back for the
television audience you're really going
to teach me a couple of moves here some
little something-something look break
off something proper for more of the
Rich Eisen show tune - audience Channel
239 on DirecTV for free on BR live or
download the Rich Eisen show app